quand plus tard on étudiera les
phénomènes mineurs de la france de la
fin du xxème siècle nul doute que les
sociologues et les historiens du temps
s'arrêteront sur le cas jean pierre
coffe au début des années 90
cet ancien meneur de revue et
restaurateurs fait de la véhémence
télévisée appliqué à l'alimentation une
véritable raison sociale
et puis il perçoit que le filon s'épuise
tout simplement parce qu'il a remporté
la partie nouveau champ de bataille
celui des pois roses et des pommes de
terre comme un entrevue depuis longtemps
que la conséquence ils dénoncent
l'apathie cement du goût à une cause
l'industrialisation chimiques de
l'agroalimentaire alors ils remontent la
filière avec un talent incontestable et
un ton qui lui est propre pour revenir
au coin de terre originelle celui des
balcons et des carrés de chou d'où le
potager plaisir qui paraît chez plon et
dont il parvient à faire un livre
d'auteur il prévient d'emblée tout ce
qui est compliqué n'a pas trouvé place
dans ce livre qui est aussi à sa façon
celui des plaisirs minuscules que nous
offre à profusion la nature coffre
appelle la variété des cycles et des
sols préconise des techniques et des
outils raconte l'histoire et la culture
des herbes des légumes et des fruits
propose d'indispensables recettes un
gros livre vert très personnel